es ist das Signal aus Berlin auf das
viele so gewartet haben aus
Bundeswehrbeständen sollen 14 Leopard 2
an die Ukraine gehen Wendepunkt in der
wohl größten politischen Kontroverse in
die die Verbündeten der Ukraine bisher
geraten sind wir begrüßen natürlich
diese Entscheidung aber wir bedauern
dass es zu einem Vertrauensverlust und
zu einem Zeitverlust geführt hat vor
zwei Tagen in Paris was wäre das für ein
Zeichen gewesen gemeinsam mit dem
französischen Präsidenten diesen
Vorschlag zu machen oder vor vier Tagen
in Ramstein was hat sich in den letzten
vier Tagen geändert in Europa gibt es
rund 2000 Leopard Panzer die größten
verfügbaren Mengen gibt es mit rund 320
in Deutschland in Spanien mit 347 in
Finnland mit 200 und den Polen mit 247
doch sie sind längst nicht alle schnell
einsatzbereit
in erster Linie denke ich mir dass
Fahrzeuge die
industriebeständen sind jetzt überholt
werden und dann auch geliefert werden
das wird natürlich ein bisschen Zeit
dauern aber hier sehe ich eigentlich ein
größeres Potenzial zu liefern als aus
dem Beständen der Bundeswehr klar
scheint das Deutschland als
Herstellerland die Hauptrolle beim
Zusammenstellen der leopardverbände aus
den verschiedenen Ländern zukommt beim
Treffen von Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg und Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius gestern in Berlin klang das
bereits an die Kompatibilität und das
wird immer unterschätzt die
Kompatibilität der Leopard Panzer Typen
der verschiedenen mit die die Partner
haben weil genau dabei kommt es dann
darauf an welche Einheit welche Verbände
kann ich wo zusammenschließen die dann
auch was Nachschub und Unterhaltung und
Instandsetzung dann auch vernünftig
versorgt werden und zum Einsatz gebracht
werden können Allah darauf bereiten wir
uns jetzt vor auf Rüstungsindustrie und
bisher kommen mit dem Einsatz der
Leopard Panzer Aufgaben zu die
koordiniert werden müssen die Panzer
brauchen Ersatzteile Munition es könnte
noch kompliziert werden diese Leoparden
diese panzerbitzen diese Mörder bei
denen wird es nicht bleiben Verschleiß
aber auch Zerstörung werden wir erleben
und deswegen muss Industrie jetzt
gestärkt wird wir brauchen diese Art
Kriegswirtschaft wir müssen Industrie
befähigen jetzt schon Rohstoffe zu
kaufen Elektronikbauteile weil wir über
die nächsten Jahre das Gerät brauchen
wenn wir nicht nur die Ukraine
unterstützen wollen sondern auch selbst
wieder verteidigungsfähig werden wollen
ein anderes grundsätzliches Problem
könnte in Washington gelöst worden sein
dort gibt es Medienberichte dass die USA
ihren Abrams Panzer ebenfalls liefern
wollen überraschenderweise Deutschland
Soldaten
und bevor wir dazu den Grünen Parteichef
befragen kurzer Blick in die Ukraine
selbst da steht für uns live unsere
Kollegin Katrin Eigendorf Katrin guten
morgen noch mal wie reagiert die
ukrainische Regierung auf die Nachricht
dass die Ukraine nun doch Kampfpanzer
von Deutschland und den Partnern bekommt
ja guten Morgen
ich hoffe dass man mich hören kann wir
haben hier zurzeit Luftalarm deswegen
versuche ich mal ein bisschen lauter zu
sprechen es ist gut dass der ukrainische
Präsident sich man kann mich gut hören
das ist gut also der ukrainische
Präsident hat sich bislang noch nicht
dazu geäußert und ist bewertet das
relativ zurückhaltend ich denke mal er
wird abwarten wie sich der Tag heute in
Berlin entwickelt bevor er eine
offizielle Äußerung dazu machen wird und
das Kommentieren wird der hat seinen
Büroleiter allerdings sich da zu äußern
lassen und der hat die Entscheidung in
Berlin begrüßt allerdings noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass man jetzt
schnell zu Entscheidungen kommen muss
und das ist vor allem Dingen auch um die
Frage geht wie viele Panzer letztendlich
geliefert werden darüber wird man ja nun
auch noch mal entscheiden müssen ähm der
stellvertretende ukrainische
Außenminister andre Melnik hat sich auch
dazu geäußert er war ja ehemals
Botschafter der Ukraine in Berlin und
einer der großen Kritiker auch der
Debatten und er hat das als historische
Wende bezeichnet diese Entscheid in
Berlin was ganz interessant ist wie die
Bevölkerung das bewertet man sieht im
Moment auf den sozialen Medien der
Ukraine überall Leoparden also Leoparden
T-Shirts Leoparden Tiere also die
Debatte um diese Lieferung von Leopard 2
ist ein wichtiges Thema in der Ukraine
das sieht man daran und in der
Bevölkerung wird das sehr begrüßt das
ist jetzt zu einer Entscheidung in
Berlin gekommen ist Katrin vielleicht
noch kurz zur Situation vor Ort wie
gesagt wir hören die Alarm sie reden bei
dir im Hintergrund du meldest dich ja
heute für uns aus grammatosk im Osten
der Ukraine wir können uns das auch kurz
hier auf der Karte anschauen es ist
nicht weit von der frontschilder uns ein
bisschen wie ist die Situation vor Ort
ja wie man das ja hört im Moment ist
hier wieder Luftalarm die Stimmung hier
in der Stadt ist schon sehr angespannt
weil sich die Situation in bachmut ja
sehr dramatisch entwickelt hat also
inzwischen können wir als Journalisten
da auch gar nicht mehr hin die russische
Armee ist dort weiter vorgerückt und das
hat natürlich direkte Auswirkungen auf
die Sicherheitslage der Stadt je näher
die Russen hier anrücken desto größer
auch die Gefahr das kremators
angegriffen wird man sieht hier hinter
mir wir sind hier im Zentrum der Stadt
die Stadt ist so gut wie ausgestorben
überall sind die Fenster hier auch von
nagelt mit Brettern es gibt nur wenig
Menschen die noch auf die Straße gehen
ich habe mich gestern zu einem Gespräch
mit dem Bürgermeister von tramatosk
getroffen und der hat mir die Lage so
geschildert dass sie mittlerweile gar
nicht mehr in einer zentralen Verwaltung
sind sondern sich aufteilen über die
Stadt der Bürgermeister auch immer
wieder sein Büro hier wechselt weil sie
einfach auch Angst davor haben das ist
hier Anschlägen kommen kann also das ist
die Lage hier in kramatos die ist
durchaus angespannt live aus der
Ostukraine Katrin Eugendorf vielen Dank
Katrin